[Music]
what's up guys it is no secret that
doing is probably the most anticipated
sci-fi movie and now that new images
have been released let's talk about
everything we know about the upcoming
film right now on the catcher bringing
Frank Herbert's beloved 1965 novel to
theatrical life has been a long and
bumpy road one that includes multiple
attempts a couple failures and
eventually the 1984 Universal release
from an up-and-coming director at the
time David Lynch try looking into that
place where you dare not look you'll
find me there staring back at you that
film is rotten at 53 percent on the
tomato meter mostly because it tried to
cram the vast world and story that dune
is into 137 minutes which is why when
fan favorite director Denis Villeneuve
agreed to try his hand at making dune
for legendary entertainment back in 2016
he insisted it had to be done in at
least two parts which brings us to
present-day where the first of the plan
two-part adaptation is in
post-production and currently due out in
December of this year
and perhaps most importantly it has an
absolutely stat cast and we can now
better visualize thanks to new images
that were recently released it's like
doing porn and that cast includes bear
with me as they try to pronounce these
names right starting with House Atreides
Oscar Isaac as Duke Leto Rebecca
Ferguson is the now expanded role of
Lady Jessica and their son Paul will be
played by none other than Timothy
sha'lame but maybe Puli Fineman from SNL
should plan because her impersonation of
Timothy Shalom a on SNL at home was
spot-on
[Music]
so when Shalom a or Paul takes over the
production of spice on a desert planet
of Arrakis aka dune he will go up
against stellan skarsgård as the villain
Baron Dimitri our Conan a character
Villeneuve is given a bit more dimension
compared to the one in the novel and his
sadistic nephew glosso Rabanne or beast
played by dave bautista but can we also
get Dave to play the guy with no teeth
in the new Tiger ki movie that was
awesome and while on Arrakis Paul will
be mentored by two raging
in Josh Brolin's gurney Halleck and
Jason Momoa Dunkin Idaho a role that
could become more important down the
road if this does indeed spawn a
successful film series and along with
giant sandworms Paul and Friends will
also run into members of dunes seemingly
indigenous population that includes
Javier Bardem as still gar and zendaya
as a mystery woman named Shane II whom
we got a bonus look at recently thanks
to her Instagram wait you're being
serious right now when it comes to the
future of dune as a franchise success of
the first two installments could open up
the door to five additional novels
written by Herbert where his doom cycle
spans thousands of years and eventually
shifts its focus from Paul to his son
Leto the second plus there's a ton of
spin-off material written by his actual
son Brian and sci-fi author Kevin J
Anderson seems like the tomato doesn't
fall too far from the tree
tomatoes don't grow on trees you know
anything and Warner media is so
convinced that June will be a success
this time around that they're already
developing a spin-off TV show called
dune The Sisterhood for HBO max one of
dunes screenplay writers John space
wrote the pilot and Denis is expected to
direct the first episode and serve as
executive producer spice undefined spice
so friends it's time for us to kick it
over to you now do you think this
adaptation of June will work let me know
all your thoughts and feelings in the
comments section and also for a planet's
worth of binge guides and streaming news
head on over to Ryan Tomatoes calm and
to keep this conversation going or just
to profess your love for Timothy
sha'lame like I do be sure to join our
ketchup fan group on Facebook and if you
don't want to miss out on any future
episodes of this show why would you be
sure to hit that subscribe button and
education bell as always thank you for
watching the ketchup my name is Perez
and we'll see you guys in the next
[Music]
you
[Music]